there were a couple wins against this
woke craziness this week the big win uh
was that claudean gay is now the former
president of Harvard she has resigned
from her post at Harvard after the
anti-Semitism and plagiarism Scandal
we've got some info here from Greg price
who's another journalist I don't have to
put air quotes around breaking here is
Claudine Gay's resignation letter to the
Harvard Community she writes it has been
distressing to have Doubt cast on my
commitments to confronting hate and to
upholding scholarly rigor to bedrock
values that are fundamental to who I am
and frightening to be subjected to
personal attacks and threats fueled by
racial animists now interestingly uh
Colin I referenced you earlier uh this
week on the show because you had a
prediction about how she would behave uh
once she would resign and you absolutely
nailed it so here's Colin Wright a
couple days ago prediction Harvard
president claudian gay will resign but
she will not admit any wrongdoing
instead she will claim to be the victim
of a racist right-wing Witch Hunt that
is impacting her mental health and
causing needless distraction for
students and faculty and then of course
here's one more from Greg price with her
doing just that uh breaking Claudine gay
just published an oped in New York Times
where she decries attacks on education
and expertise says she fell into to a
well-laid trap before Congress and says
that the people uh and says that the
people to called for her F who called
for her firing trafficked in lies and
stereotypes about Black Talent so yes
she did exactly what you predicted Colin
I suppose that that little man who tried
not to move too much in the meme is not
surprised by any of this no I mean it's
not difficult to predict when you
observed how these typ typ of
identitarians work so remember the
objective of ideologies like CRT it's
not to ask whether racism occurred but
really how and to what extent a given
interaction was fueled by racism you
know they believe it's just baked into
every social interaction imaginable and
then we've seen the people like you know
the usual suspects Ibraham kendi
regurgitating those you know their
pathetic rehearse lines about how this
is white supremacy and we're all afraid
of black Excellence uh you know he
actually said that gay wouldn't have
been investigated or pressured to resign
if this was a white woman but you know
I'm coming from a science background we
actually have a near perfect natural
experiment to look at that controlled
for these relevant variables Liz McGill
at Penn was another female president ivy
league university facing backlash for
identical remarks at the same
Congressional hearing but unlike gay
McGill was white and didn't have 50
charges of plagiarism against her and
she received no support and resigned
almost immediately so I mean these these
claims are just so easily debunked it's
completely at a with reality right and
that's the irony and I said that on Fox
a couple days ago to me it was like the
anti-Semitism thing I actually think
because she was a black woman she would
have got away with it it was only
because of 50 plus counts of plagiarism
that finally they were like all right
this is this is a bit
much